hello everyone I hope they are good new
trading week and as I say in yesterday's
Bitcoin soon the update I have the
feeling that this week might be quite a
boring one because we don't have any
major news announcements all right
especially today on Monday because it's
a bank holiday Day in the US it's a
Labor's day so even if Bitcoin is open
24 7 and you can try any any time
if the stock market is closed Bitcoin is
Gonna Fill that in the chart and there
is going to be a lack of liquidity okay
which can trigger less volatility in the
chart right so not expecting much for
this week but if we go into detail and
we start with the weekly time frame you
can see that this week
we left this Candlestick here right with
a very long week
so I think that's a week that could
potentially get filled especially you
know considering that you know you have
here the mid range that's the 50 of the
week also and the weekly 50 May and also
the daily 50ma you know it's coming down
and it's gonna go towards that soon too
so I may be again for the mid range you
know if you remember
uh some weeks ago we were saying okay
we're wearing this range over here let
me market
okay
that was your range then we were saying
that the market make it was building his
shorts and it was very likely
to see
you know a fake move to the upside a
deviation Above This range before coming
back down then consolidating the
resistance and let you have the drop
towards this previous range okay you
have then two potential supports you
have the range size okay you can see
there that was resistance twice that
could have been active support so you
were waiting to see a deviation here
to make some business in this Zone
otherwise prices are not dump into the
range loads okay and you can see that
that's what happened but right now the
range slows and if you notice what is
going on here
all I see
is that we are testing support testing
support testing support you know we're
holding our support so
um my long from here from 31 414 I think
it was
I told you in Twitter a couple of weeks
ago well actually when we were here this
day are totally okay you know I'm out of
my shorts my shorts are done from from
from that level okay and I was looking
for
um a pump here because I was telling you
the other day that by looking at the
condition hit Maps I could see quality
of liquidity here that would even hit if
you notice here about a couple of
hundred dollars only so we were talking
about the adapter this aggressive drop
you know the little trailer is going to
be escaped and it's the one I want to
put any money on the table on the chart
okay so if you induce Traders with a
large green candle like this one then
Traders are gonna open longs and then I
want to put some money in the table okay
and then you've got some unemployment
data this can be pumped also you got the
grayscale
ETF news you know Market pumped and then
it got retraced
literally two days after all right so
you can see Dynamic psychology is there
the psychology of the move is currently
happening they are developing a movie
okay inside this zone now you have to
try to understand what is going on and
I'm sticking to what I said previously
which was that you still got a wig here
that is not filled okay at twenty
thousand seven hundred so in my opinion
what I've been telling you this for a
couple of weeks okay I expect some
consolidation here
okay yes it's in consolidation but
eventually we want to break down and
we're probably gonna go to the watch
this week that's what I think especially
now that we are below the 50 EMA in the
weekly time frame you can see that here
he acted as support one two three four
times now you got it as a resistance we
just hit the resistance okay what about
if we do some more tests and then we
drop
right that's what I'm saying in the chat
so uh that's in my opinion the
psychology of the move now that doesn't
mean da let's go to the table again that
doesn't mean that
we might still see some more
consolidation here
you know and this means a pump right so
in the short term you know as we're
holding above support I can open new
shorts here
I think it's more likely that we see
another pump okay maybe towards the
mid-range because what I've been telling
you will have a lot of Confluence there
so that's what I'm looking for
uh to happen this week okay again you
know if you lose this support
and you drop below this Zone here and
you consolidate then you know you want
to go lower
and then that's when you can open shorts
here okay even if you lose you know one
thousand dollars in a position in price
it doesn't matter because you know it's
gonna happen okay you know then it's
going to happen that drop and still it's
gonna be uh four thousand dollars
of a drop
right so plenty of profits to be made
there but as long as we're holding above
support you know I prefer to close this
short right that sort is closed
and you know
again here I have no reason to open
shorts I prefer to look for bounces okay
we managed to get these bounce can you
get another one
I find it quite likely to be honest I
find quite likely that we see a new uh
you know one thousand dollars uh pump
this this week why not it can happen
Okay we're above support so that's what
I'm thinking we might see this week
if I'm honest with you and let me take a
lower time frame okay you're gonna have
a problem here because you have the four
hour
50ma
so that would be a resistance ball if
you manage to get above it
then I can tell you I wanna pump to fill
this liquidity pool over here and also
this one over there okay
um another that's another conference we
just found okay that's a mid-range those
are the kind of setups that I'm looking
for okay now one hour time frame let's
see what we find okay you know Square
boarding you can see
you know getting above the 1 or 50ma
that will give you some kind of a bounce
again check this out that's a crazy big
liquidy pool here
blue liquidity pools must be blue
otherwise they don't work
guys as I was telling you that this
liquidity pool over here
could get retrace
that one there
that's basically the same
as this liquidity pool here
okay so tell me a reason why if this one
got retraced
then why can't this one get retraced too
okay
uh so those are the kind of setups that
I'm looking to trade this week now in
terms of altcoins
I've been training somalcones this well
I just close some positions if you go to
Solana in Solana you can see that we've
been testing the one or 50 meter
resistance but we didn't droop further
okay we just continuously making higher
lows you can see here right so that was
telling me okay we're gonna see some
kind of a squeeze and that and I thought
that's going to be to the upside okay so
around here 1935 I think I got it
1935. I got this pump and it exclusive
that
1984 okay now that that trade you know I
didn't want to lose some opposition in
price because if you notice here
it's true that you got some Wicks to the
upside
and price is not breaking through okay
yes you got this week which makes me
think we're gonna continue going higher
but
um that was a very good
um trade for me so now what I'm waiting
here is if price maybe retrace is today
we test again
the 50ma and that's when I can open
another position I'm targeting this week
as the first take profits okay but of
course here you also want to have the
problem for r50ma you see that
right so that is telling me that if we
see the drop and I can open a new
position then I'm going to close my
trade in this one here because that's
this week over here and also the four
hour 50ma
right so again these are the types of
trade that I want to get in now when
that is not much volatility in the chart
but if we see a pump
get above the 4 out 50 mate test it as
support then you know you can Target the
security pool here or this one over here
all right so that's a few
um ideas with Solana same happened with
chain link
another episode that I took okay this
one was last night and I don't even know
how I caught this okay I entered at 6.03
again
I didn't even know how I entered that
book that was a thing around here maybe
there was literally before going to it
okay because I saw that in the four hour
time frame
we just go above the 4r50ma
you can say that and we were testing a
support so that was telling me okay a
pump is imminent why when I see a pump
okay happen in the chat so I enter
quickly and then I went to bed so I
wrote this trade from 603
to so from here well I think it was
around here
okay
to I think I around here okay why again
for the same thing because this looks a
bit of an extended again it could pump
here
all right but
this might drop a bit and retrace maybe
towards this level
okay and Paul cadot
I'm currently in the straight in
polkadot because polkalot hasn't pumped
yet okay and I entered also last night
in this little line because this was a
previous support if you go to the Daily
time frame
you can see there all right
support support
so last night I went into this chart and
it's okay
this might have in a deviation
I don't know because now we're above it
above this level and we tested our
support several several times okay and
in the one hour time frame
you can see that we still haven't pumped
aggressively from the away from the one
and 50 mates so in my opinion
it's likely but don't do something like
this okay and that will probably take
you as you can see there to the 4 Hour
50ma
all right so even if Bitcoin is not
doing much and you don't have you know
major news announcements it doesn't
matter you can still trade
of course you have to be cautious
probably more cautious than usually but
you can still find some traits all right
so that's in the very short term uh at
an inflator today or tomorrow I'm gonna
post a video about
um my perspective or my view in the
article Market I'm not gonna be charting
um you know again different coins there
is already two videos maybe I'll do a
third video in the future but I want to
bring you a brief idea of what I think
that the altcoin market could do next
okay so uh that's pretty much everything
regarding the charts and I would like to
take you back to bitcoin
uh let's see what Bitcoin is doing to be
honest I don't think it's when I move
much this week okay if I'm honest with
you let me remove these two levels here
okay
but anyway yes with Bitcoin I would like
to see this week
and move towards the mid-range okay if
we lose this level over here
and we are below it and we cannot
reclaim this level okay so if we do
something like this
then I'm going to open a new shorts okay
and we're gonna Target
the liquidations that we have are 23
500.
also at that place we have
uh I think we got the monthly 50ma 23
700 okay
but if we break below this then the next
Target is going to be the 50 of this
week at 20 700 okay so that's what I see
for bitcoinbo again first I would like
to see this week over here
getting filled at least the 50 which is
around the mid-range right so that's
pretty much everything now let's go to
High block Capital to see if there is
anything of Interest so the liquidation
levels in hypocapital are showing that
the Delta right now it's at uh 9 billion
dollars worth of short liquidations last
night when I did a Bitcoins in the
update I think we were around 14
billions if I'm if our number correctly
um this basically means you know if you
go around 10 billion dollars worth of
worth of short liquidations is telling
you that the position that it's at risk
right now
to the upside you can see here total
sore liquidations
338 total long liquidations 111 so that
means that for every long position there
are three short positions open
right so first you know there is going
to be
a motivation from the market maker to
set a sort of squeeze and start to hit
those liquidations okay because most of
the market is currently positioned in a
short
also if you take the spikes to the right
I also tell you these specs are very
important because it shows you the
levels
or on the direction of those liquidation
and you can see that to the downside
these spikes are much smaller than the
ones to the upside you can see that if
you check the dope so you've got here
let me have to find some right here
227 million dollars worth of show
liquidations of times 50 leveraged
Traders at 26
436 okay so 26 000.505
a lot of liquidity also you go here
traders that are insured in times times
25 leverage they got loads of
liquidations at 27k
okay that's the mid range so that's what
I mean there is more liquidity to the
upside in short term all right
and in the liquidations hit map
let's see if there is anything of
Interest so in this time frame
okay so in a lot of liquidity at 28k I
still see the level way too far away
okay I think that's around the the range
Highs but of course you know the mid
range is gonna be
um a first Target if we see a pump right
so I'm gonna dismiss this target for now
because first I want to see a reaction
of Bitcoin at the mid-range if we get
there right and if you check the monthly
I know there is going to be
a lot of liquid to the downside
there you go a twenty three thousand and
three months time frame this is a chart
that I've been talking about for quite
some time I think uh 11 12 days ago
maybe and I was telling you guys this
drop here this week is not coincidence
that would even hit this level that we
missed by a couple of hundred dollars
okay that's not coincidence
and then you got this consolidation
and I was telling you what the market
making is gonna try to do is to induce
traders to open logs how can they do
that with a big green candle then you
got that candle there
and then you can see that the
liquidation cr5 have increased so you
can see that this kilo bar are 23 600
okay
you see it it didn't exist before that
pump
I don't know if you guys can see it okay
so for example one here
that yellow bar didn't existed but then
because you saw that poomed you can see
this yellow bar is starting to appear
and that means that trailers have open
lungs with this boom so there is one to
be a lot of liquidations
add this Zone okay so you can see that
the liquidity in this zone right now
it's a lot more than what we had you
know a couple of weeks ago which tells
you that
the ultimate idea of all these moves
could be
to just build more Liquidations in this
zone so when price comes down and hit it
soon
they're gonna release a lot more
liquidity
than they could have done in the past so
this is why I also think that in the
midterm you know what Pro is still gonna
see a drop
all right so again take this with a
pinch of salt because
I'm gonna see a random person I'm giving
you my personal opinion so it might be
completely wrong but uh that's what I
see in the markets okay I think that in
the short term would this week we might
see a pump to 27k again
if it's possible but in the midterm in a
few weeks it's very likely that we see
that drop below to hit this zone so
that's what I think guys anyway I don't
want to make this video any longer so
I'm going to wrap this up here thank you
so much for watching
and I'll see you soon